performed over 5,000 shows all over
Silicon Valley for pretty much every big
tech company
we know he's act welcome back hey Bret
well we talked earlier this week about
business models of businesses that you
don't always normally think of as
businesses and this week you have a
piece on a guy who's a magician in
Silicon Valley and tell us a little bit
about his business model and what you
learned about that sure so this guy
Daniel Chan he brands himself as Silicon
Valley's favorite magician and there's
there's some credence to that branding
because he's performed over 5,000 shows
all over Silicon Valley for pretty much
every big tech company we know and he
has kind of this really interesting
story of working his way slowly up the
magic food chain starting which starts
and he's with these little library shows
here and therefore you know 50 hundred
dollars a pop and then you work up to
the children's birthday parties and then
you work up to you know the executives
home parties and then you work into the
corporate parties so it's a kind of
structured chain in the magic world and
you know once you make it can it can pay
pretty decently but he's one of many
creative people we've been thinking
about and talking to you recently who
you might not think of when you first
when you hear the word entrepreneur but
they require every bit of every ounce of
business savviness that it that a tech
entrepreneur might require and they
spend a lot of time thinking about their
business models as long as well as their
tricks and his his business model has
been obviously disrupted because of
what's happened with kovin 19 so how how
do you do magic tricks behind a zum-zum
sort of camera lens yeah I mean a lot of
magicians cooks you see it happening
with a lot of other creative professions
fitness instructors are pivoting to zoom
obviously right now
magic is tough because it's a it's a
personal visceral thing there's a lot
there's a slight of hand involved people
kind of want the assurance of being
there next to you to see the trick
happen and when you introduce a barrier
of technology it's just another layer of
the unknown that's introduced to the
trick you could manipulate things in
thousands of different ways over zoom
call so he's had to kind of reject her
his his routine and kind of go back to
simpler tricks and things that you might
be able to do it's it's kind of he
brought up an interesting point which is
magicians had to go through the same
thing when they started doing television
shows years ago so trying not to over
complicate things and just finding
different ways to present things to the
audience and then on top of that there's
this other challenge which is that you
know the unknown is a universal enemy
right now just in general we the fact
that we don't know what's going to
happen with Kovac 19:00 we don't know
how it's going to impact our future in
our economy and magic is a celebration
of the unknown so in in a poetic way
he's battling that that greater fear of
the unknown and mystery also fascinating
I'm looking forward to reading this and
I know everybody else is - make sure you
open your email on Sunday and you'll
learn a little bit more about how to do
magic on zoom' and a little bit more
about this business which is really
fascinating and how somebody as a
solopreneur is adjusting to these really
difficult times thanks everybody we'll
see you on Sunday
[Music]
you